did you see boyhood I did thoughts I
loved the film but I know some people
say that nothing really happened well
that's on the flip side but there were
little moments that were very real I
know the movie is almost three hours
long I need more than then then little
moments I also think that the the
naturalism isn't is it's not naturalism
and I'm talking about for example
dialogue that has a lot of vocalized
pauses urns and arms and your nose and I
mean and so on I think that Linklater
believes this is like real you know the
prime and it is real so what's the
problem with that well the problem with
real there are two problems with it
first of all it's available in the
streets for free you don't have to buy a
ticket and go into the movie theater or
hire a babysitter drive to the theater
park the car pay for the ticket to see
what's real you can just step out into
the street and see what's real the other
thing is that what's real is more for
the most part I could tell you about my
day today everything that I could tell
you would be true and contemporary and I
really really knew what I had for
breakfast the route that I took to get
over to the campus the context of three
meetings this is a big meeting day the
first Wednesday in the month so I was a
tad bit to three meetings today I love
my colleagues and I thank God every day
that that God placed me in a place like
this at UCLA where where creativity is
is happening and I'm allowed to do
creative work but these were not
terribly exciting meetings I could walk
you through the agendas of those
meetings and you'd be fast asleep it's
even though it's true and and it's now
again we want boredom in our lives and
we want to passion and excitement in our
art do we really want boredom in our
lives and we do I was my brother-in-law
who's a lawyer was here this past
weekend and when I picked him up at the
airport I said I was the flight and he
said bor-ring what he meant was it was a
great flight at left on time it came in
on time imagine another response oh what
a great it was fabulous flight for one
thing there was a near miss when we left
Stapleton or whatever the airport in
Denver now and then there was buffeting
and and turbulence and in fact one of
the two of the flight crew were injured
on the way over here and then well we
blew a tire on the runway and I and one
of the engines flamed out yeah I mean
this this is not an excitement that that
we want we want boredom in our lives and
passion passion in our art can you think
of a film that's a mixture so it's not
to realized sorry but it's not even say
most films are mixtures but don't but
not because they try and mixtures of
boredom and and interesting true or most
films almost like boyhood you mentioned
there is some merit in boyhood I'm
conceptually it's fascinating using the
same actors and and and so on but I
don't want a concept I want a story I
want to get engaged by events that are
one related to the next and there's some
of that to be sure in boyhood I know
people I love and respect as tasteful
and brilliant people intelligent people
who love that movie so there's no wrong
a write about it and I didn't hate the
movie I know that doesn't know on the
marquee didn't hate it Richard Walter
UCLA although that's a pretty big
compliment for me some people would tell
you people who know me but the the fact
is that boy that's a perfect example of
a movie that has that's kind of boring
and kind of interesting from time to
time what I want a movie to be is
constantly interesting
I was totally engaged
my imitation game from beginning to end
they were able to comment on some very
very weighty and difficult issues
without ever getting preachy or
intellectual about it
bully bullying homophobia issues
involving war and peace and life and
death should we tell these people that
they're about to you know the the Nazis
arewe with their u-boats are about to
sink this convoy and we can say well the
lives are the people in the convoy that
way but that will also tell the Nazis
that we're on to their code and that'll
they'll change the code and we won't be
able to read them anymore and that'll
cost more like these are very
interesting questions and their answer
in a dramatic context without ever
becoming a lecture about principles or
protocols or anything like that now
there's nothing wrong with with lectures
on principles and protocols but movie is
not the place with that I sometimes say
I remember I was arguing about the
DaVinci game The DaVinci Code when it
came out I was in the media a lot
because there was a friend of mine
actually he said he's become a good alum
on Bill Donohue he's the head of the
Catholic League and we kept meeting on
these talk shows that we became friends
he was opposing of the movie the release
of the movie because it was inaccurate
he said historically the way it
presented the history of the church and
that it also was inaccurate with regard
to the theology the way it approached
the you know Catholic theology and my
answer to that is and and was up the air
then if I were hungry
and I have a hankering for a tuna fish
sandwich I like to take my time when I
say these things because I imagine
people wondering what I think what was
he going with this if I'm hungry and I
want a tuna sandwich I don't go to the
hardware store and if I'm looking for a
lesson in history
or a sermon in theology I don't go to
the movies I'm gonna get bad theology
band history bad moving so lectures in
theology and history have their place
places right here I'm honor we're having
this conversation on a campus one of the
great world centers of higher learning
the universe California here in Los
Angeles and it's appropriate that there
should be on our 265 acres or whatever
we got here in the middle of LA it's
appropriate that there should be
lectures on history and Thurman sermons
in theology but not in a movie
you